this next email comes from Christian GU
Thurman Ralph and Kevin my name is
Christian I'm from the Dominican
Republic with the name like GU Thurman
I'm thinking your relatives escaped
Germany at the end of the war so they
wouldn't be brought up on charges
hmm Adolph change your name then I will
be Goutham on Goutham on when you
announce the ABCs live musical version
of The Little Mermaid you led us here Al
Pacino's audition for Sebastian the crab
is it true Christopher Walken is also in
the running I think I heard the fact
that uh that Chris Walken was also
auditioning for Sebastian the crab that
may be true I wonder what his audition
would sound like the seaweed is always
greener in somebody else's lake you
dream about going up there that is a big
mistake just look at the world around
you right here on the ocean floor such
wonderful things surround you what the
[ __ ] are you looking for under the sea
under the sea darling it's better down
where it's wetter take it from me up on
the shore they work all day out in the
Sun they slave away while we're devoting
full time to float me under the [ __ ]
sea yeah I think he'd make a good
Sebastian you're very kind
[Applause]